Well. Well, well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Well,
your dad
and
your dad.
Tick bite,
Tamir.
Tamir,
the blood,
blood
fight, fight, fight,
fight,
fight.
And Your Dad,
the blood,
blood all over face.
There we go. I didn't realize the
song was ending. That was a bite.
The end of your dad's Dickoff
by Dj Stan Umum Hey. Yeah.
Very nice.
I'm trying to set up so I don't look like
a slack or are you sitting up in your
chair or do you arrest your back on
it? I'm sitting up. Yeah, I got a lot.
By the way, a number people were like,
oh, have you gained a bunch of weight?
And I'm like, I lost almost 20 pounds
in the last now while they're rude,
fucking assholes,
asshole as hell.
You're fucking asshole asshole. Is
this me? Hello. Hello. Oh my God.
That was me. Thank you. Hello? Hello.
That's me. You're not figure this out.
So cause I sit in that chair sometimes
and sometimes I sit in this chair,
so I get confused. Always fuck
up my shit. You know what dad?
I don't need the dude.
Okay. Uh, I mean, I got you.
I'm not mean, why do you say that
Shit today? And you're all say that.
I'm not mean. Where's your water? It's,
Oh, it's right here. It's a big glass.
I may take small sips, but I'm in it
for the long haul. Yeah. Long haul eyes.
And you might finish that next Thursday.
I'm gonna Finish it in this episode.
You'll see, um, whatever dude that
I've been doing that a
lot, John sackers here. Oh,
I didn't even mean for that to
please don't make that happen. Um,
Zachary's you've had been singing a
really annoying a Latin Latin tune. Yeah.
Do you need to do,
did you do,
hmm. Um, let's, uh, go and due dates.
This is a open one to know
the best dolomite route. All
right, thanks. I'll be one.
The SMS, the famous study.
So much music for us over the years.
You can go to ob one ob,
those number one.com.
He's got a lot of stuff you can download.
You can go ahead plug your days. Jeans.
You got big ones this week?
I do.
I'm in Dallas and in Poussin
Phallus. And boost-inn. Uh,
but by the time this gets put up,
I think ILD done with, uh, on,
let me just double check
something to your guys.
There has been a venue change October 5th,
the secret group and Houston,
it's an 8:00 PM show.
They have switched the venue due
to plumbing issues apparently.
So it's going to be at a place
called the warehouse live.
And they said they're going
to be notifying you guys,
anybody that I'm in Houston that,
that saw me last year or the year before.
Samia warehouse lives. Oh, just going
back to the same venue guys. So go there,
check me out. I can't wait to meet
all you guys. Uh, it's called,
it's been so much fun. October 23rd, um,
in her apple tits. Yeah. Is that what
it is? Indianapolis, Indianapolis,
mortise.
And then October 24th,
Cincinnati or the,
I'm famous far happen at go banana
December 9th and 10th to DCF crops.
That's it for this year. We have
so much shit going on. I mean,
we're stuttering because we're so tight.
I know with stammered through all our ads.
And how are we alive?
Okay,
go. All right. October 13 through
15, Charlotte, North Carolina.
Charlotte.
Um,
I'm at the comedy zone there shirtless
the next week. Cox Comedy Club and man,
Fran Disco,
California.
Uh,
two of those are already sold out.
So make sure you hop on
that Dick in San Francisco.
Oh my God. Get tickets. Only
a couple of nights of Cox,
uh,
Carolines on Broadway in Jude or Kitties,
I believe two are also sold out there.
So do you want to hop on those nuts
while you can? Uh, and then Raleigh,
North Carolina. Oh, what's
Raleigh? Oh yeah, I dunno.
Rod. Rod Meat's good.
Well, I'll work on it.
I'll work on it.
That's the only two nights that I'm
coming for it to November 4th and fifth.
So those, uh, Louisville,
Google, Kentucky. I'm
doing the laughing derby.
Couple nights there in that room.
Yeah. Yeah. That's a great room. Yeah.
Trocadero intimate in a,
fill her up.
Delphia we sold out three,
so we added one more.
It will be the final show. If you're in
Philly and you don't have tickets yet,
you want to come
is the last night that
there's going to be,
but this is the fourth and final edition.
I'm going November 18th and
19th to Fart Adelphia. Yeah,
and then my last gig before the
year ends is Harry palm hairy balls,
Beach West Harry Paul
with Harry Palm Beach,
Florida at the Improv. December 2nd
and third. That's it. That's it.
That's our year is the year
that new years. So we have,
I have a new year's Gig,
but it's not confirmed. So it is confirmed
but does, I don't know if it's on sale.
Oh, okay. I'm just choosing not to
say it. Yeah, just curious. All right.
I'm tired.
You already goes back.
We have been traveling both of us
and then when we're home recording
shit taken care of the baby.
Our any had is a personal thing.
Yesterday happened so we had to,
you know, it's been a lot. Yeah,
we have and it's slept and
what a year now. Crazy.
Just keep on this with coffees for right.
I know. Keep taking coffee cares. Yeah.
You ready to do this and be dead soon? It
won't matter. I know. Yeah, I'm excited.
I'm,
you know what though?
I always enjoy doing your moms house
cause it's always a vacation from whatever
adult thing is happening. You know God is
real, you know. You know what I'm saying?
And blessed blessing. Why did you
play that? Why his guys real? No,
that last part you played that. What
do you mean? Why did you say that?
God is real. Oh boy. There
you go. I cut it off guys.
Real God is real.
You got to face the camera at all.
Don't forget cause otherwise they're
just looking at the side of your well
versus the way it is going
to go. Okay. Wait a minute.
I downloaded caffeine like you guys
told me too. Why doesn't it work?
Come on man.
How about there?
No sleep and sleep.
Yeah. All right. Right.
Well Shit. Okay. That's okay. You
ready to do this? Let's do it.
And I know you think everything
has to do with genes.
Well,
I've been on, I know a lot
of billionaires. And to
the best of my knowledge,
I never saw one wearing a
fucking pair of jeans. Not One.
Okay.
Not One.
No.
Bring it
to your mom's house,
Christina.
Well,
Dan Pena to get the job gone.
There's nothing better than Dan Pena
will fire you up. He's my absolute,
they write, look at it as some
orthopedic old guy's shoes.
Those were wearing orthopedic.
Yeah.
The old guy shoes. But the rest is
definitely done up. Yeah. It's also the,
the screen is for, as you know, it stopped
right now because the clip is over.
Yeah.
But he is a hall of shame.
Yes. In his workshop. Yes.
So he's putting people on blast there.
Yes.
Um,
but then you also get to be one of
Dan's like special mentees. Yeah.
And then you get put on another wall.
So are those people that are currently
taking the class right now? There's no,
Oh, the wall of shame or past people and
Hollis. Okay. Are douchebags dip shits.
He's like, fuck these people go
fuck tweet. Fuck with fuckers.
And then these guys are the
idiots that paid a $12,500 to go.
How much it is. I think it's around that.
I get the emails now. It might be, um,
I try and 12 grand to go to his castle
for a few days seminar in Scotland for a
week, a week seminar. And
he's so funny. He's like,
everything I have is written in my queue,
what he calls it,
the quantum leap advanced or something.
The QLA that's his program.
I read his book online.
It's unintelligible.
It's got like random sense and
that's like lol, exclamation mark.
Every other third sentence in his
book it says that, yeah, it doesn't,
I tried reading and it just
doesn't really make a lot of sense.
It's not very cogent. It's like not
well written, but he would tell you,
cause you're a fucking mongoloid. Yeah,
I'm going to youtube fucker. Yeah.
And he also shoots on people watching
him on Youtube. Mongoloid is watching me.
Yeah. Here. Um, he's
just an old military guy
now. Apple have, you know this,
and I'm being sarcastic and I'm being
a cheeky, uh, the Sally and I, uh,
I've lived all over the world.
We used to live in Monte Carlo.
This is how they dress.
So if you're listening,
he's wearing like a velvet,
uh,
like dotted Tuxedo jacket without a
massive black bow tie and almost like a
floral patterned shirt
underneath it tightly.
Yeah. World. He, oh, he usually wears
a Tuxedo to class. He looks, it looks,
that's crazy.
Yeah.
The pigs, you know. Oh and I, uh,
I have lived all over the Woolies live
in Monte Carlo. This is how they dress
pigs, you know, and this is
my, this isn't even dressed up.
Okay. Yeah, yeah. No,
it's dressed up there.
That's how my dad used to
talk all the time. Everything
has to do with gene. Yeah.
Yeah. Jeans. Um,
I remember when I did my semester abroad
when I did Spain. Yeah. Their main thing,
they didn't really talk about
American behavior, you know,
cause a lot of kids were louder
and more obnoxious Americans
that went over.
They were always like,
we know an American cause you guys
dressed like shit. Shit. Yeah, it's true.
When I go back to Hungary to visit my
family, yeah. That's the first thing.
They talk shit to me like,
oh the fucking blue jeans and my parents,
both my parents, if you went
to the doctor, you dressed up,
you didn't wear a fucking genes.
Right, right. My Dad hates jeans. Yeah.
So does mine. Yeah. I hate,
well good genes don't like
jeans. I know. Doesn't either.
Okay. Just look sloppy. And I used
for years, he used to be like,
you got to shave that when I had
more just like scruff. Yeah, go.
No, let me just look scruffy scruff. Yeah.
I don't like it. And now he
likes her. He would say that too.
We're going to go to this
dinner. You can't wear jeans.
And he would get excited.
Kind of excited to say that.
No, you can't wear jeans.
How does he feel about your beard now?
I think it's so many years, I think.
And it's, it's bigger. So it's accepted
as part of, yeah, it looks good now.
Whoever that guy that fucked you
grew back nights is that his plan?
You think I'm going to give you a haircut
that in three weeks you're going to
love.
That's his formula.
It might be what are your next three weeks
looking at it because you're going to
look like shit.
You know what the irony of that horrible
thing happening is that you've been
performing in these enormous venues where
it's not that the audience is intimate
with you, you're up on
a huge screen. Right.
So people are looking really at your
face more than jumbotrons. Yeah,
like stadium size jumbo trons right.
So you're getting scrutinized more
now horse than ever before. Let me,
let me see what my love Dan has to say.
And I know you think that somehow designer
jeans, I don't know what that means.
I have some,
in fact,
how many got genes in the last four or
five years and my kids think it's a riot
when they see me in him.
Yeah, a designer jeans.
I guess it's because when they cost
seven, 800 bucks, I guess that's um, uh,
you know,
that's the definition designer.
Did you probably don't have to pay seven,
800 bucks from genes. But anyway, uh,
I hear at Costco you get James for 80
bucks or 80 year olds or 40 year olds.
I can't somehow, for some reason
women's jeans cost more than men.
Does anybody know why?
Because women are stupid.
Yeah. Keep it playing. I know.
Ain't know why?
Because women are stupid
and they'll pay more.
That's why there's less material
unless you got, you know,
some big fucking hog of a woman. But
the, uh, the mortar love I guess.
But, uh, I don't understand why
women's jeans, anybody on Youtube,
you little fucking wimps.
Uh,
email me and tell me why women Jane's
class more when there's less material.
Unless you've got a big hog.
He's such an old military dude.
Yeah. Yeah. His background is that,
so he just lives like he's still in
the military. His philosophy basically,
I'm going to say whatever I say
and you can go fuck yourself.
He believes it. I think
I believe that too. Yeah.
I think I might hold a similar
philosophy if you were more famous.
In other words,
if he was part of the mainstream,
it would be really funny to hear, you
know, these talking head news shows,
interviews you just said, and
he'd be like, fuck you. I wish,
I think that's why he's not more well
known. He just doesn't give a shit.
And that's not as refined as a a Tony
Robbins, let's say. Oh yeah, but he,
by the way, I watched, I haven't
finished that, that flicks thing.
[inaudible] he curses a lot
more than I thought he does.
And he says he does it to jar
people out of their everyday. Yeah.
But he's also got a refined,
and he's a good communicator,
refining refined message. And this
guy has done, unfortunately. Yes.
You a fucking hog. Like
Tony Rap. Yeah, no. Yeah.
Tony Robbins is more of a feel
good. He's kind of crazy. You know,
he's just an old military. He's kind
of nuts. Absolutely. Out of his mind.
He's absolutely, but he made
a ton of money. Most of it,
I think doing these
seminars. He has, uh, this,
this inflated a number floating around
out there, you know, I don't know.
What do you mean you don't know?
I know that he made a lot of money
as a CEO of some big company. Yeah.
And then he was fired as a CEO,
and the next day he started the seminar.
And I don't know what his actual value is.
I think the $50 billion
thing is when he was a CEO.
He made that much for this company. Right.
But I don't know if that's his actual,
you know what he's worth now?
I don't know. Yeah, I don't,
I don't definitely got money though.
I don't doubt that.
I don't doubt that he has money.
I don't think that he's
a worth $50 billion.
He's never, never been mentioned on any
of these. No. That's what I'm saying.
The $50 billion is when he was a CEO
of some company and he made that much
revenue for the company. But he personally
didn't do it for like his own company.
Right. Why? No, but so, but that leaves
in the question, what is that guy?
What is he worth? It's not out
there. I don't see it. Oh No.
He calls himself the $50
billion man. Whatever. We just
a couple of Youtube fucks.
Anyone you should listen to his podcast.
It's so funny cause he answers people's
questions. That's the whole thing.
And every answer is like, I dunno, it's on
my fucking website. You Fuck, look at it.
Tweet. Fuck it. Like
fuck it. I don't care.
So he's the worst podcast and the
audio quality's terrible. Good. Good.
Yeah.
I love it here.
You do by loves you.
But yeah, but in my case,
yeah, I love you, but I don't
want to have sex with you,
you know? And uh, and I just, I
could live just on lust, you know,
and I'm 70 so I mean,
but I love your youtube.
Okay.
Hey,
Chinese got any Chinese shit to say?
All right. Dang. When Jane,
okay,
so he's,
he does a shit or he's just racist.
Now there's a Chinese girl in this,
right? And he like shits on them.
He'll shut on you. It's just whatever
your race is. Yeah. And he's like, Hey,
Chinese got any Chinese shit to say.
Dang Wing Jing Ping. When
gene, he does that a lot. Yeah.
He just fucks with you like whatever
your race is, whatever your thing is,
he'll just fuck with you like they do in
the military. You know he doesn't care.
No, he definitely doesn't
care. Oh Man. And he out.
He talked about it before
on youtube where he's like,
you fucks can write in the comments.
I don't give a shit. Fuck you.
Like he doesn't care. He's like, I'm not
politically correct, but Chinese thing,
their access to soften this
clip earlier and then a girl,
a Chinese girl actually that's who
he's talking to you. Yes. Yeah, yeah.
And somehow for some reason
women's jeans, they, um,
so far are we supposed to
be watching it? Well, no.
So I'm expecting a fuck up then the
next day or two because it, it's gone.
I want to hear her talk on girl
and I haven't had to pivot yet.
So it's,
it's obvious are important because at
least somebody in the team and the way I
show up on Youtube, oh my God, I love you.
You too. Bye. Love you. This is a,
but in my it misunderstanding,
I'm just asking if you have any comments
and you're, he's got any Chinese
shit to say. Dang. When Jane,
uh, please say it again. Slowly.
That's a Chinese girl.
He says that to their fence
normal and there's like,
I saw one clip with like a Chinese dude
and he's like, I could change John.
Ding Dong. What do you
have to say? It's like,
actually I have a question like he did.
They don't care.
They're used to it right there.
It was that a retarded person could,
you said you have a question. Is that
what you're meant to do? Chinese retarded.
I'm a huge damn pain your family. I
just, I can't get enough of this guy.
It's hard not to be or not to be.
You know what he really preaches though.
I'll tell you what the, if you
distill it and I've read his website,
I've read everything.
Yeah.
He really breaks down
people sense of fear. Um,
his whole thing is like,
do one thing a day that scares you
because if you break down people's fear,
you break down the fear of failure.
And the fear of success and you'll
do whatever the fuck it takes to be
successful space. So that's
what he's doing. He's like,
stop being a fucking pussy.
Just do it asshole. You know,
who cares whatever you are.
Chinese, a woman, whatever.
Like he actually does like women. He
said that he, he refers to like, um,
female CEO's the crater of
Victoria secret. That woman in
some other video I saw like he,
he gets it, but you know, yeah.
Whatever it is hard. Dang. Dang.
Dang. Dang. Dang.
Dang.
It's one of the best songs you've
ever had made. Ching Chong. Yeah.
I think there's a good one that
came in from Jenna. Oh yeah,
she submitted one. We played this on
patriotic, but we put that shit down.
Overlooked it for your mom's house and
we know it came in after it came in
afterwards episode. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Um, yeah.
Let's see. It was all types. We,
we never fully get to explore all the
great music you guys send in cause you do
send an incredible music
and um, yeah, this,
this latest one was from
Jenna, is that her name?
Jenna, Jenna. It's water
champ song. It's really good.
Yeah,
she did the thing that I think uh,
um,
ob one did once was that
she pieced together things.
Setting conversation, right.
To make it flow like a slog.
Actual things we've said.
Yeah. Jenna. Uh,
uh, this song is called Watergate.
You want to hear it? Yeah,
I'm standing there and I smell what
smells like somebody just dumped an entire
container of coffee in the shower like
somebody took, I don't know what that is.
Okay.
Like do you think you could
drink water today? Dad
always been a big water
drinker. Oh, bull shit.
I have your P is like Brown.
We should measure who drinks more
water in a day. I do in a second.
I think it's me more than two to one.
Why don't we do a water challenge?
I'm fucking challenge you right
now, Bro. Okay. Okay. Let's do this.
It's so ridiculous. That's
ridiculous. Accurate. Not even close.
I drink so much water and after set.
Yeah,
I'll let you get off stage. She was
taking, he's like a little baby.
So I think what's your
water intake funds all day?
We have a new logo that just
says, Tom, the water champion.
I may shoot flowing your age to know
and they can see the manipulation.
You could never drink as much water.
There's online support. Instagram,
Twitter with Tom is the best done a big
fat liar. Here's the evidence to wait.
Remember? Wow. That is so false.
Hello Yana.
That wasn't a lie.
That was just misinformation and the
truth is more Stonewater all talk.
No hydration. It's a marathon. You're
sprinting. Big, stupid, stinky, dumb bear.
Lot of water,
no drinking.
I'm the tortoise and the hare
while on the road performing too.
You hydrate with club soda. I drink
more water than you. You're a Bush jr.
This is Florida.
Who gets the Sparklets in the house?
Who makes sure that shows up?
Where's your water? A mug.
A tiny little shitty cup of tea.
Drink less frequently because
you're dehydrated severely.
Those of us that hydrate properly hydrate.
People want to hear that.
It's so you drink like an animal.
This is all for the cameras.
You know that he never does this when the
cameras are off, your honor, your honor.
For me to the fucking pint and it's
sit for you. That's a sip for me.
That's the point is I'm the one, I think
this is where the confusion comes from.
Probably had like $70 this week. You're
not drinking enough water. Sorry Tina.
You need to work on your concession
speech and water champion.
You're going to happen. Is that
the truth will come out eventually.
It's a long race. I sit all day. If
we can contextualize that properly.
You're such an imposter corridors
of water in his house. Your honor.
If Tom had enough water,
he wouldn't be Dj dad mouth.
Do you know why you're a fucking loser?
You drink water with losers.
Please go fuck yourself.
Stupid fucking Twitter followers.
Microscopic sips of water. Look at
the physical evidence. Your honor.
Time will tell you. Do your sprints
and I'm in for the long haul. Bitch,
the tortoise wins.
Okay.
Is the SIP chain Gavi? Yes.
Beer. Oh and bounce off.
It looks like melted lies.
Propaganda. I am prevailing.
I drink more water than you do you
think so? You're the water winter.
In the same sense if I were to play, you
know, basketball with our son. Right.
And I'd be like, you're the winter
too. I think you agree with them. No,
I'm not even sorry mommy. Tina, you can't
win against natural talent like that.
So mad because I burned you so
good there, right? You talked to,
but you talk stupid. I just knocked
down to a sippy cup like it was nothing.
That is nothing.
Okay.
Wow. Oh, that's so good. It's
called Watergate Emami desk track.
And just so you know Tom. Yeah. Are
you listening to me? Yeah. And lifting.
The reports are in from San
Jose. I have my eyes on. Yeah,
a lot of Twitter people letting me
know. Yeah, you did not drink water.
He did not hydrate at all during your
San Jose said thank you. Wanti minutes.
Yeah. But yeah, I'm sorry.
Did you guys hear that?
He just goes, this is 20 minutes. Yeah,
but if you're a real water champion,
constantly hydrate.
And those of you that saw me in Seattle
in PDX will know that I had a special
dress made to contain
to Fiji water tonight.
Walked out on stage both nights
and I drank. No you didn't.
I sure did both feet,
but I brought them out cause I had my
primary water and then my backup water.
How much I hydrate the showmanship.
Oh Wow. And performance. What?
It pours your water, right? You're
sort of the, where's your water?
Donald Trump of the Watergate.
You're like, Oh, you talk a big game.
You got
all these stories. I say you don't
drink a lot. You got wrong, wrong,
wrong. No it never did that. Tom, where's
your water right now? Water Champ.
I drank this already and I put
regular water into this. Can show me.
Show me the regular water in there.
How do I show it?
Let me see it. Let me taste it.
Is their regular water in there.
Let me taste it and pour it into where
him and let me taste it so that I can
verify that you're finding you got yours.
Let me taste your regular
water and Lacroix can,
it's quiet and I uh, I'm drinking it.
It's mine. You have your own. Okay.
Just so you guys see the people watching.
I have a full huge cup of water and he has
no water on the table. Thank you. Yeah.
Yeah. I rest my case. Thank
you for keeping these reports.
Uh, keep them coming in.
Guys. Let me know. And every city, Tom's
in, whether or not he's hydrating onstage.
Guys, thanks. Wait, wait.
Told you get the report from Charlotte
or Manfred disco where I'm up there an
hour and they're gonna be like, Holy
Shit, they drink three gallons of water.
Why isn't this working guys? I
did. I downloaded it carefully.
It's not working.
So fucking upset about that.
Activate anti sleep.
Yes.
Activated. You know, you look like
right now that comb in your beard.
What you look like.
Captain Lou Albanna. Yeah.
Well from the 80s, he used to have
rubber bands and shit and his beard.
Remember that?
I remember the Cindy Lopper in that video.
I see you big wrestling fan.
No, but I liked captain Lou.
Rowdy Roddy Piper.
Okay.
Of course, man. Thank
you for your thoughts.
Thank you for your cross. Sell
them again. This is my home number.
All right.
We got translations and number,
our fluent Farsi listeners wrote in.
This one came in Fartsy fartsy people.
Uh,
it says, here's what's going on in that
message. Hello. Salamay how are you?
I wanted to tell you someone I
wanted someone I wanted to know.
Thank you for your thoughts,
but,
but me and then someone interrupts like
we thought she did and she goes, shut up.
You have to go. But she talking to someone
that erupted her. She's a solid man.
I'm sorry. This person calls me
sometimes. Then they wrote this part.
Falling part is unintelligible.
She mumbled something about the person
who interrupted her. Then she said,
I eat normal. A regular normal. I know.
Anyway, thank you for your talk salad.
My dear. This is my home number.
You can call me to talk to me. Bye.
Less from Pierre [inaudible] and uh,
my buddy who translated a
bunch of the earlier ones,
um, on, what's it called on uh, Instagram.
What's it, what's my best
slam on? He wrote to me
basically. Yeah, the same thing.
Thanks for the talk. She'll
shut up, go away to the person.
Uh, he says, I've been eating a normal,
I don't eat nonfat stuff. Just regular,
regular, regular. How funny. Yeah.
What is going on? So she's got some
dietary discussions, some squirrel,
and she's thanking solve
me for consulting with her.
They are still doesn't know her number.
Still doesn't have a clue. I know.
I'm just excited that the voicemails
have kept like they're coming again now.
I started and now I'm feeling bad for
the color that she doesn't connect with
Sallie Mae as much as she wants it
sometimes. She's really nice to sell them.
Me Tell him he doesn't even know
how much this lady cares about her.
I know she's always thanking her. I
know. What if settlement is like, God,
she's so ungrateful.
I gave her all this great dieting
advice and she never said anything.
I told her to put bags in the trees
for the squirrel. I never heard back.
Sallam he was like this
fucking bitch. Yeah. Um,
speaking of ladies who speak aggressively,
you want to see something
this time we're going to say my name.
So you guys don't know that I have
a different name. So are we going,
see, I have a name, let's spell it.
A R r o y o dash.
G. U. Z. M. A. N. Okay. You
know those names you should.
Okay. Overall your city council
thing. Yeah. Yeah. They,
they put these on TV,
see span or public access and the,
it's the town meeting.
Someone can be on, you know,
there's no, there's a pothole on my,
so Maria used to go, I keep going, keep,
keep driving through it or was she
going to do something there? She uh,
she's all kinds of crazy.
That's like,
no,
my brother was here checking you guys out.
So it was my uncles do you know you have
scratchy toilet paper and he really got
treated bad. So you know what he said,
you go buy them some toilet paper,
get everybody to start
bringing toilet paper in.
This is at the city council meeting.
This is her beef.
She just busted out a four pack of
Angel Soft, which is a good brand.
But I thought she was going to be like,
you guys poison the water and my brother
drank it and died of lead poisoning.
But no toilet paper
because you know what? Let's, let's
do some, let's clear up some things.
I have two boots,
not six.
I have six bucks because when you guys
are talking about me, you have no idea.
Who knows me.
Um,
I had twins.
See that young man back there.
That is investigator Schaffer.
Badge number 1193 clap for him because
he protects you guys from people like me.
You know the people you screw over.
Why does she have two boobs
but six buckets? I don't,
she's talking about like her relatives.
Like I have six people behind.
Like if there's yeah, my back. But I got,
I got to you don't have six tits though.
No,
but you guys caused the depth
of somebody who should have net.
Oh Hey wait a minute.
Women,
I got marbles here because who in their
right mind ever thought it was okay to
put a concrete company 50
feet from a family home?
What are the marbles do?
Oh No,
Carl, you got me my transcripts yet.
There's six hours of them. You got them.
I put it in writing. Notarize certified.
That document. Where are they at?
I asked you a year ago for them.
What? You just think I'm stupid.
You guys have no idea who I am.
I don't know what she wants. She's
been wheel Oh, just a little.
You do think she is?
I mean,
I'm going to ask you just fire it up.
Unless these are select clips from a
bigger piece that we're not seeing.
All the information is just,
she's got the marbles,
the toilet paper,
six butts to tits and
a private investigator.
It sounds a little paranoid.
Come over and look at antelope project.
How come that's fallen down already?
Go look at Harris Bridge.
I got a funny look and Harris Bridge.
Why do you already have structural damage?
Because you can't put crappy,
crappy material in the concrete.
But you guys let it all
happen and so you know what?
I'm going to be here every single time
there's a meeting. Cause guess what?
We're going public,
aren't we?
Okay.
How much of a bomber or would it be if
every time you're on city council and you
have one of these meetings, you see
her in the, in the seat, you're like,
God dammit. I know. What did she,
did she bring like a fucking a
fishing knife today? I know. Yeah,
but I got a feeling these
city council meetings,
this is the majority of
who shows up. Yeah. Oh,
like lunatics because who the
fuck goes to these like, yeah,
just crazy people with nothing
better to do. Right. Like you would,
you and I would never have time cause
we're too busy leading normal lives.
You know what I'm saying?
Well,
you know what I'm supposed to do.
I was supposed to give Roger Fire
Guard some panties. Got In pink.
I won't say what goes with pink.
These are for Mickey Esposito.
Since everybody's panties getting a wad
when I come up here. So send them to her.
Okay.
Wow. I like that she went
shopping for this appearance.
Yeah.
This reminds me of my mom.
My mom had a problems with everybody like
that. That's, that is she would have um,
gone to something like this. Yeah. If
my mom had a beef with the city, yes.
If that would have been her target of
choice versus like my Stepdad and um,
a few other things on the Internet.
Yeah. I feel like could have like,
I kind of wish she had this outlet.
Yeah.
I feel like this is
really good for this one.
Do you think your mother would have
led out four letter words? Maybe? Yeah.
Oh yeah. I'm calling them Edwards and
you fucking these up piece of shit.
Fuck you. You fucking cunts. She
loved to call people. Consequently,
I never heard an n word. Really? I only
had a few meetings with your money. Yeah.
You needed to come around
a little more. Oh, really?
Went to clean out her apartment.
There was a black security guard lady
there and I was talking to her and uh,
and, and she goes, yeah, I
know your mom eat it. He was
quite a character. She goes,
uh, you know, she was always nice to me.
She never called me a nigger and I
was like, I'm sorry. She was like,
she called other people that but not me.
So you know,
that is a nice testament to
my mother's a manners. Wow.
She called her and she called the front
desk lady at con. My mom tell, yeah,
you dropped a big word, but it was
in the context of a story. Yeah.
Yeah. This woman's clearly paranoid and
angry and yeah, it's pretty great though.
She seems together, which
is misleading. Right.
And like she doesn't look that crazy
together. Might be the wrong word. Yeah.
She bought panties, toilet
paper. And what else?
She brought one more thing with her.
She had marbles. Marble. Yeah. Yeah.
Panties for a man. Pink
panties for men. Yes. Yeah.
So there's a lot of victimization.
Did you see me in a book? Not a
porn book either as a Cindy. Okay.
I made a lot of money in
a book and guess what?
My Dad called it dental floss.
And guess what I did with it.
I put it away for something like
this and I made a lot of money.
There's a lot of men has that book.
Uh, yeah. What she needs to meds. Yeah.
She didn't take her shit today. Well,
I have not seen, shouldn't take a mets.
I'd only seen the first clip before
this, but this is the, the clothes.
You already see the clothes.
Oh, what's her clothes there?
I can't imagine it gets better
and so you're not in my city.
I looks pretty good now.
I'm fat as a cow now.
Remember I have six buckets,
not six boobs.
All right.
All right. That's it. Yeah. My mom would
say things like that too. We were like,
wait, what do you mean I have six
bucks? Not Six boobs. Fuck you. Fuck.
You know what? My mom picked fights with
nuns to when I went to Catholic school,
fucking bitches. I'm like, okay,
you're picking fights with nuts.
You're crazy. Yeah. No, I
mean, I wish there had been,
that was so crazy and it's just,
it's too hard to follow because
we just really out of her mind,
you know, I wish I had a
little more focused, like I
don't know what she's after.
Well, AH, yeah. That's the thing is
that when there are that spun out,
they're really sick.
Citing a thing
that could have been like what?
Her beat her prime, right? Yeah.
Usually it's that someone's out,
it sounds like she's thinking
that they're all out against her.
I think the private investigator
stuff, like that's another layer. She,
she's being persecuted by all of them.
And the concrete company.
I got to tell you this, so last night.
Yes, sure. So I was in, um, San Jose.
Yes. The odd ball tour. Yes. And
we ride up from the hotel.
It's Swardson,
Diaz and I. Right. And
they're just driving us.
Everybody else has their own trends. You
know, people would come different ways.
So, but when we want to go back a ds,
and I want to go back at intermission is,
it's just he and I,
so as a driver who works for live nation
and Diaz and me as we get in the car,
at first we're just talking about this,
talking about that. And then, you know,
sometimes when you're on particularly
longer drives highway drives,
there's just moments where it kind of
goes quiet and you feel the feel of the
highway beneath the,
the tires kind of has that rhythm.
It's kind of peaceful. Yeah. To
do. Yeah. To do at night. You know,
you see sometimes you could see
stars are like the way that the,
the highways lit up. Right. There's
kind of a tranquility to it. Yeah.
And we hit that moment. There's no radio
on, so you're just hearing the truth.
I'm staring out the window and that
silence lasts about 15 seconds or so.
And then Joey goes,
I would tell you about the
time I saw a guy's stomach
put on the tenderloin,
I go, no. And I see the
driver's eyes in the rear view.
Like he goes like, oh yeah, it was
cut open from side to side. Yeah.
His blood was brown. It, that's how
long he'd had been bleeding out.
People just stepped over him. Oh
my God, what a fucking up that guy.
It was a crazy time. So
those days I was like, yeah.
And I just keep looking at the
driver and he's like, oh yeah,
guys stab each other.
Starting knife fights other than
know what the fuck is going on?
Running the other way, guys just
stabbing each other crazy shit back then.
That's just from a dead silence.
Yeah.
Joey really has a net for
those moments. Yeah, man.
It's amazing what a life it is. A
magazine had a crazy life, Huh? Yeah.
He says a lot of funny shit.
So much of it is not even repeatable.
Even in the context of our
show, I wouldn't be able
to set it up. Right, right.
Yeah. He's so outrageous. Yeah. He's not
even outrageous. It's just like you can't,
I don't even know. I don't even know
how to prepare someone for it. Hey,
literally have to experience it.
He's out of his mind.
T do you know who McGruff the
crime dog is? Course doesn't.
Joey Diaz kind of sound like him? Um, I
don't remember her bite out of crime. Oh,
right. Um, I think,
I feel like McGruff the crime dog
is Joey Diaz and you be right.
Could be,
uh, that's Jenny. Jenny's dad.
If he could send it that car and
maybe the last time you'll see Jenny.
Oh my rough.
The crime dog.
He knows kids every day
in his country disappear.
Oh my God,
I'm running runaway,
but a lot are kidnapped by strangers
or even by people I know. So. Right.
The McGruff and teach our
kids to protect themselves.
Love the shop by picked up by that I
cry. I mean I could, I can hear the
molarity for sure. I think, um,
I love these ads by the way,
that they just terror terrify you.
I have a bit about this now in my act
about how we raised ourselves in the 80s
yeah. And commercials
like this. Yeah. Like I,
they just scared the shit out of you
into compliance and that's the way you
should do it. Like, hey kids, you'll
get snatched up off your God damn bike.
Don't talk to strangers. I think Joey
would be a little different than,
than the McGruff dog. I think he'd
be like, you see this kid over there?
I can take that kid if I wanted to.
I could get now like yeah,
you can just tell you about
crimes that he could commit.
You want to do more crimes?
He's committed before.
That'd be [inaudible] guys dealing drugs.
I got drugs to eight kids. Yeah. And
then Joey will be a great McGraff.
Oh yeah. Really, really fantastic.
What's his Dad Boehner thing?
Dad boners things about abstract
painting. Do you know about this? No.
What does that mean?
Page?
What is that? I had, I didn't send that
to you. That's terrible. That's horrible.
Can you please play the guy,
the touch therapy guy? Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Is this a called all touch therapy?
You email this to me?
I did. Okay. He came in, um,
through our email and I watched
it and I was like drawn in.
I was immediately drawn in.
Oh my God.
What I'm looking at it,
this guy gets paid to cuddle strangers.
My name is Karen and I
do professional cuddling
and the accident and he has vocal
fry, vocal fry, intense vocal fry,
a nice car.
And I do professional cuddling.
Can New York City.
God,
uh,
I'm a professional cuddler.
Tom Can do you think he
went to cuddle in college?
God has a bachelor's and cuddles may be a
cad said professor.
Of course. Honestly, I don't even
want to split the word coddling.
What do you like going to
name this therapy? I would
call it alternative touch,
I guess to kind of touch like
everybody loves when the, at the salon,
they shouldn't pull your hair.
Do like that. I like that.
Okay.
No.
So con schedules one cuddle session a
week through cuddlist.com $80 an hour.
So he has one a week.
Then he charges $80 so he
makes $8 a week doing this.
Is that a ton of money for New York City?
There's gotta be more.
How many of those people are just
dudes that are like, oh look,
a cuddle on my mouth. I like alternative
touch right around my asshole. Yeah.
Yeah, for sure. There's a spot
on the back of my ball bag,
like some alternative touching too.
If you could alternatively use
your tongue and then exactly mouth,
they'll feel good. Alternative Swirl
might come again down one a week.
I think run a week using this site or
something. Right. Cause it said a site.
I cuddle list.com so maybe it's like a
cuddle, like a Craig's list for cuddlers.
Yeah. Cuddlist oh this is
such fucking horse shit.
Can you even believe that this nice
looking girl has to pay for cuddles? No,
she doesn't have to pay for that.
She was so thrilled to see him though.
I think it's a friend.
I think she likes him.
Look at other like embracing $80
an hour for this lunatic to cuddle.
Make my apartment somewhat of a health
or wasted this apartment or Chinatown
have shitty apartment.
They raced to hospital grade
nanoparticle air purifier.
[inaudible] gets the chem trails out.
Think can train.
All these plants are a
little living room plans.
So bringing the first oxygen humidifier
essential oil diffuser that I drink
myself has been multistage.
Purified and distilled.
Yeah.
What's Your Pronoun?
Relax. You don't need to
do all that. Okay. Okay.
Certified cuddlers received special
training to keep themselves.
What are you feeling like
you want me to rub you?
You want a spoon on everything?
Um, Tom here. She just, she
just wants to bang him. Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
Oh, okay. Physical touch.
Some times with clients.
We'll talk about the elephant in the room,
which is why are they coming to
hire a professional cuddlist?
What is their perfect collation
ships with intimacy? You know,
their mom never hugged them.
Their wife is very cold to them.
Yup.
I hear you con all those things.
I'm going to New York,
autism,
Asperger's spectrum that I just have
never been able to engage and a natural
intimacy friends, they don't even,
you know, high five their friends.
It's just been a very isolated,
physically isolated experience.
It's a lot.
He's just lucky.
He's doing stretches and he's got hi
ladies do with the pressures. They go,
you want me to stretch you? You're
like, no, no, no, no. It was dry.
You do that. You're really doing a lot
of offensive stuff. This, wait a minute.
We haven't even discussed this a lot.
First of all, what's your Pronoun Today?
Oh yeah.
Which Braxton are you?
I feel like we don't know. Yeah.
It'd be like, hey, hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey, hey,
look what? Oh, I saw you walk up. You
just be like, Hey, I just saw you.
I saw you walk up and be like, Hey,
what'd you promised Dan? Ma? Yeah,
it was a printer.
What's Your Pronoun?
Which Braxton are you
then tell me your pronoun.
Watch which Braxton?
I feel like I feel like Towanda today.
Like I got the kids,
I got the husband, I got, I have so
many things I'm juggling right now.
Um, I feel like I'm, what is the, uh,
what's the big girl? The big
girl. Oh, she's the funniest.
Braxton. Yeah. Wait, hold on. Tony. Tamar.
Towanda we have to sing the song again.
Oh,
Ooh.
So
Ah, ah, wait,
but do you like being
stretched by the Tire Lady?
I mean there's times if I do something
really intense exercise wise, yeah.
Where I feel like it's good for
me. In other words, you know,
your hamstrings are rack, you go,
well this stretch is going to help me.
But I don't, I still don't enjoy it. It's
never as good cause I know it's better.
It's always too much pressure.
They go too far with the stretch.
It always hurts. They're like, does
this feel good? You're like, no, no.
It feels terrible. Start
it. And you're like,
oh, that's what it feels like.
Right? If it was like shit.
Yeah. That's what it feels fucking
hate when they stretch me. This guy,
this guy's fucking dad. What do you think
you is Joey Diaz was a professionally
laid out. My took your head, do some
stretches. It was smuggled. Been well.
Yeah.
Why is that a tender?
Like I consider that
so many people, my best friends
from so many different peoples.
Single only best. Oh Man.
Cause I think that is,
that's why I think I'm good at this.
Best friend might know me,
I just have disabilities or make
someone feel like they're the whole,
my whole focus.
Right,
right. He's a nice guy. He's sweet. I
actually think for this week on artists,
right? For people with Asperger's
or some kind of, you know,
social anxiety stuff, that's
probably really helpful. Yeah.
But it is a bit of bullshit. You
know, a cuddlist a professional.
I love when he's like,
I have a an air purifier.
I have triple purified water.
He'd done yawning into the mic.
I mean I had to go, am I boring?
You know I had Dion. We May. Do
you want some coffee? Yeah, thanks.
It's nice and cold lake you like thanks.
It looks like Brown diarrhea listeners.
Could you say that more?
What? I mean I'm trying to, oh,
like that's going to deter you from
did determine why don't you tell him?
Tell him about my neat farts that
I had. No, it was just disgusting.
I just got home a little while ago and
we were leaving a room to basically head
up the stairs and you were a step
ahead of me and you turned around.
You put your hand back and you placed
it on like my mid section. Yeah.
Just went wait and then you
had like a three part four.
It went online
and I go,
do you not want to keep any romance
going? None. That's my line by the way.
I say that to you. No, I
say that to you. I said,
are we going to do this again?
What are you talking about?
I say that I've said that to you.
Remember last time you farted on Betsey's
head and that's the first thing I say.
Do you like,
do you even want me to have sex with you?
Is You farted on Mitsis head?
You sat on our chair in the bedroom.
Yeah. You were in your Chobani's.
You put your legs in the air.
Yeah.
And her face.
She started smelling your be whole and
then you just blast it or be home or out
of your be whole and then to her mouth.
That's the secret. It was really gross.
What you did don't, Hey, wait a minute.
What? Why are you, you're judging me.
How dare you. Shame me. You've
taught me to be like this.
I was a woman before I started dating you.
What are you talking?
You turned me into an animal.
No, dude, I would never do that.
When you first started dating.
Yes you would.
And then you turned me into this pig than
I am now. Why are you putting it on me?
Cause he years of being with
you, you've broken me down. How,
how you've been saying that for years
because it's true. I was a lady before.
I mean not totally,
but more of a lady. No,
I think it was this hot chick.
Um, why don't you use the
ginger is your favorite. Yeah.
Why don't you tell them what's going
on? No, I think you should do this one.
How come?
Because this is your jam.
You are so excited.
You sent this to me like two weeks ago.
A potty mouth Dunnville teacher who
slipped into foul territory before facing
the new charges. Dunnville secondary
school teacher. English teacher,
Jennifer Elizabeth Green Johnson
allegedly told a student,
why don't you lick me where I fart?
Okay.
Why don't you lick me Fart.
That is so good to a student.
Yeah. That's not that bad. Right?
It's not that crazy. Yeah, it is.
How old is the kid? Um, I dunno.
It's elementary school babe. Yeah.
I think my mom told me to do crazy
shit like that didn't tell you to lick.
You were, you know, she'd be
like, go fuck yo smell my farts.
Who really not lick me. Yeah. She's
say crazy shit to me. Smell my farts.
She would say,
um,
she would fart on me and stuff and she
fired in the closet and push me in the
closet and stuff like that. Wow.
Wow. Your mom didn't do that.
Your mom did that. Oh, stop. No Way, man.
Lick me where I love the,
is this an Ontario and Canada?
Hey, my birthplace birthdate.
Yeah. According to the, what is it?
Brandford expose expositor Green
Johnson has been a frequent flyer at the
Ontario College of teachers and the
Grand Erie district school boards,
that disciplinary committees,
she's been suspended for 30 days last
January for professional misconduct.
Among the most recent allegations that
data 2015 she slapped a student on the
head, called him an idiot,
told him to grow some balls.
She allegedly called one student,
a bloody pedophile,
told a female student she looked
like a frumpy old lady today.
She slammed on her students, has
stupid idiots, gay and a bitch.
Jesus. She's got a lot of it.
Um, so this time, let's see.
I feel like we're going to see her at
the next city council meeting. Yeah,
I feel like she might be a fan of the
show. I think she was at that a live show.
We didn't Toronto a couple of years
ago. She's a mommy. Uh, I think so.
Dan Pena is not a mommy.
That's really good fans. Um,
appears that students aren't terribly
fond of her on rate. My teachers,
um, most commentators slam her
although several are favorable.
One comment was awful. Teacher
bully to all students. Um,
swears that students all the time last.
If you don't know the correct answer,
very unprofessional. She is the
worst than a bully. Immature.
I think this is totally unrelated.
This, yeah. I'm like, wait,
what does this former Ios applied teacher,
Mary Beth Haglin famously had sex with
one of our students a hundred times.
She's, she's not stripping. Um,
she's now working at a strip club.
Woody's
just a few miles from where she taught.
Oh that's nice.
That's a nice little button to the story.
Has nothing to do with this story.
I think it's there.
What do you think they put that
there? Cause they were like, hey,
who's this girl and panties
anyways, Ligonier, I fart.
Really cool.
You know what?
I do regret that we don't have audio
because it could be another kiss my pussy.
Right. I suck as it suck my
pussy on a bloody day. That
was another good one. Yeah.
Yeah.
Like me where I fart
ass.
Yeah. But I wish we could
get a lick. Me where I fart.
I think that's a really neat phrase.
It's really cool. It's really cool.
Speaking of phrases,
oh I'm the patrion show.
We were discussing how you and I have
used a phrase around this house for like a
couple of years now. Yeah. Which is
same shit. Different toilet. Right.
And we never really do it on why image,
but it's in our private lives. We are,
well it came from why IMH though?
Originally. Yes. And then it, it's,
we say it almost daily
around the cigarette
was interviewing Adrian Broner
on Hbo and Boxing Fighting,
you know, as a whole UFC even. Yes.
Some, sometimes you hear outrageous shit,
but boxing especially lets people get
away with saying just the dumbest shit.
And the most, like they don't
have any, I mean, it's kind of a,
it is refreshing because you see such
a cookie cutter stuff in the four major
sports. It's always like we were trying
to find our identity and I hate that.
So boring loop. It came with it. We did
the best we could. It's always the same.
This is from that.
This is one of the Oh gee
clips we played from that.
Kellerman Adrian Broner.
Yeah.
Marco, as it were. Just one of the reasons
you are as hot as you are right now.
What do you feel about this?
Which is after all the followup
performance to that masterpiece, you know,
same shit.
Different toilet
chewing gum. That's such a good
line. Yeah. Oh, you know, same shit.
Different toilet. It's a great line. Yeah.
What's this guy's name is Adrian
Brody runner. I love that.
And I love talking about practice. Those
are my two favorite athlete clips. Yeah.
Tuck. Talking about practice.
Not, not, not, not a Sunday.
Those are home run clubs,
man. Run Iverson. Allen
Iverson. That's right.
You finally got his name down after 15
years. Yep. Adrian Broner. Yeah. Yeah.
He's a shit different times. He's been
on the show a few times, actually.
He's done some ridiculous shit to,
um,
who's the guy that decked out his van
with $100,000 worth of like Versace,
Louis Vuitton. You're talking
about two or 300 guys right now.
Not that pacifically.
There's one player and then
Allen Iverson documentary. Yeah.
That he refers to. He's like, oh, that guy
is fucking crazy. He decked out his van.
Like he bought a fucking van.
I Dunno. Maybe it's Allen.
That wouldn't be surprising to me.
It's not an outrageous claims with me.
Gosh, by the way. So I see
this here. You know, we just
played it. That's your hero.
You know that, right? Of
course. I know who that is.
He and I go way back.
We have an intimate relationship.
Apparently there is a,
uh,
a new documentary coming. Oh,
all about Rocco.
God,
I don't think,
I don't think I need to know.
Very interesting.
Yeah.
Uh,
he told me some crazy
stories. Yeah, he did. Yeah.
He and I were talking when you were
filming something. I'm serious.
Like I was shooting. No, you're
doing a Russell Peters presents.
That's where I met Rocco behind
backstage behind the dumpsters and yeah,
in between. Um, now he did tell
me some crazy childhood shit.
You told me that, which I'd be fascinated
to see if it's in this documentary.
My mother always dreamed up
roadmender like my father
or your parents struggling month after
about what do you want from life to give
him something better.
That's what I dropped out.
I told myself, you must do something
to help your mother or did it.
So I used my cock, helped me out.
I told myself he'll help me. God.
Yeah, there you go. Hmm.
Um, so anyway, interesting.
There's an article in vice about his,
uh,
this upcoming film and these,
I guess these guys followed him around
for pro while they asked him at one point,
why do you call your penis
the devil between your legs?
And he says, uh, because
the devil takes your body.
It's not you taking him for so many years.
I use sex for my convenience
when sex is using you, however,
that means you are addicted
and it's the devil.
It's the same if you take
drugs or alcohol. All of this
is what I call the devil.
He makes you do anything he wants.
He makes you do things.
You don't really enjoy it, but you
do them anyway. Um, it said, oh,
because we've mentioned this before,
it's not the first time he's
talked about retiring. Yeah.
What happened when you were 40 and you
said you'd be working just behind the
camera as a director, he said, I
tried to retire from my children.
I wanted to stop performing
in front of the camera.
By the time they were teenagers and
were ready to have sex themselves,
I tried to do things on the other side
of the camera in order not to hurt them
on the other side. I fucked up
so many times. First of all,
I hurt myself by stopping.
Secondly,
I started to go to hookers two or three
times a day, so three times a day,
hooker, hooker, hooker, because I
was used to having so much sex. Wow.
So then he went back to performing
for us. It's got a real problem. Yeah.
It sounds like he's got an
addiction a little bit. Um,
this is something that I wanted to,
uh,
show to you because it's, um, yeah,
it looks like we have a
picture of the poop pile. Uh,
possible file ladder.
See?
Yeah, I saw that. Come in. Let me see the
top of it. Is that what that looks like?
It was similar to that. It
was similar to that. Okay.
I just want to show if you're,
see there's the steps up here.
See the way that we had it, few steps
were nailed to the tree themselves.
And then how so how did you
shut off the steps then? You,
you didn't set up the steps.
There was a ledge like this off the side
once you climbed up high enough so that
you would face the tree and your ass
would hang out the other way. Sure.
You know what's funny is that in
all the years I've known you a,
I've never seen you climb
steps up a tree you,
that's like worse for the last,
I'm saying that you're not
a climbing agile person.
It's not your stairs to climb up
anything and Shit to do anything.
It has everything to do with it. Cause
if, especially if we're taking a dump,
you really gotta be committed.
Anyways,
I got this interesting
email from the poop pile.
The poop pile itself emailed us.
What did it say? It says, Dear Tina,
I exist.
Fuck you.
Love poop pile.
See
I guess I guess you're right.
Yeah, yeah. I guess the
poo piles it real. Yeah.
See he emailed you the guy
speaking of gross things, we got
an email that says, hey mommy's,
I just wanted to ride to say I just got
done licking my first asshole and it was
pretty,
pretty amazing.
I've been dating this girl for a few
weeks and decided I would steal her heart
by um, by eating her ass. Yeah.
We talked about it over text
and she was totally excited.
I was extremely hesitant at first as
I've heard Tina's thoughts on poop coming
out and all that jazz. Yeah. But
she doesn't even hydrate properly.
So what would you be not about eating?
Yes, they go hand and hand. Alright,
so overcoming my fears
of the stinky abyss.
All I asked was that she shower
right before and then came the fun.
I had her face down,
ass up and I just went for it.
I was pleasantly surprised
of the silky feeling.
It gave my tongue and
was even more surprised.
There was not a shitty taste or smell.
I won't bore you with my technique
as I'm an amateur currently.
Overall I would rate it 10 out of 10.
She loved it and I have to say I enjoyed
it also. I highly recommend Tina.
Give it a try to Tom. Yes. No Way.
Your power from Salt Lake City,
Utah Johnson. No thanks. Thank
you Johnson. And yes, Christina,
hopefully this, uh, makes you think,
first of all,
you
would have to have your butthole
totally waxed. Like baby soft. Yeah.
And then you would have to have it steam
cleaned, steam cleaned. What's that like?
You were seen on like the Braxton's they
went to get their vaginas steamed. Yeah.
I want you to go get your butthole steamed
so that it was thoroughly clean and
then maybe I would do it.
Your shits are fucking nasty.
You love town the other day and you left
streaks in the toilet that I couldn't
even believe how many it was. It was
light brown, like real diarrhea. Well,
I'm not going to do that
right before I go, you know,
before you go to tab your lunch,
I'm going to clean it up.
You know when you have your lunch too.
When's your um, colonoscopy. I
have to change it again. I do
because of a gig though. I'm gigging
man. I'm gigging Bro. I am though.
It's interesting bro. I'm Gagan
for real. Uh Huh. All right,
so how long are we going to put
this off? Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
How long are we going to put this off?
I need a new day. A new day. Oh Jesus.
This doesn't look real.
This is out of habit.
Tantric Orgasm all by
herself to throw off,
bring them into your being
and he looks like Baloney.
Have we played this guy before?
The rest take care of itself? No.
I'll show you how it was. Remember,
I feel like we have, yeah,
cause the guy just breeds,
I remember this and then he like goes,
well maybe it was audio back in the
day. Video. I remember a guy like,
looks like he's no chest hair.
I'm going to fucking puke.
I hate why it's turned on.
It's like watching a guide jacket.
I don't want to watch her. Oh, it's great.
Look at them. I'm going to throw up.
I just don't like it,
but I want to know who's not teaching me.
He just watching some guy imaginary.
I want to, I want the lesson.
Well, it's like a wet dream. Yeah.
It's all in the mind, right? Yeah.
Oh look how hard he's coming.
Okay.
Thanks for making wine.
Uh,
some tight jeans on there.
You have it under one minute,
but here's the, I don't want to see
anymore. Oh man, I don't need anyone.
I don't want to see him in
speedos either knowing it.
I'm trying to get out of it. I want to
see his erection. Here's he had a boner.
Better tantric orgasm and under one.
Does he have a boner first?
Get a little high. The guy did a
couple of minutes ago so he's out.
Sit back. But he's not teaching us. Hello?
Somebody you want to pull into your energy
field. Okay. I can't, I can't do it.
You went over number one.
One comment. Somebody hand
me a trash can so I can barf.
I don't want to hear him coming. Can you
not? My friend today is master shake.
Oh yeah.
I don't want to hear it
bro.
Bro.
Can't do it out of this one. All
right. Okay. That's just grow.
I hate hearing dudes do nasty shit
like this. Yeah, he's a nasty.
Why you gotta you gotta be so nap time.
Why? Why you gotta be some nasty. Can
I read you an email? We got of course,
but I need you to really pay attention.
Your focus is very important. Sunday.
All right,
let's do it.
This might be the most interesting email
we have ever gotten. Are you ready?
Yes. No, you have to listen. It's
very interesting. Okay. Hi, Mommy's.
Do you think if a human eight
only dog food right and or wet,
that their shifts would
start to smell like dog shit.
And you know that very
distinct dog shit smell.
Yes.
What an interesting,
interesting topic.
This might be the dumbest email
we've ever gotten, but I like it.
It's really dumb. So dumb. But I
like it. Okay, so that was down.
But listen to this part. This part is not
dumb. It really does give me pause. Okay.
Okay. Also, why is it that animals
don't need to wipe after browning?
Why doesn't brown stay on?
They're buttholes like it would
ours if we don't want. Hmm.
We maybe we need to call in
Brown lock to investigate.
I would love to hear your expert Brown
opinions. Well, you know, I haven't,
I haven't a couple of thoughts.
Love you, Jen. Thank you. Jen.
What an interesting question. First of
all, thought provoking. Couple of things.
If we just eat dog food
dry and wet,
it will smell like dog should
I think. I do think so. Yes.
So you think?
Yes,
it would see using his dog food.
The legs, the dog shit smell
like dog shit. Well, why
don't we try and experiment?
Why don't you do it for a couple of days?
I'm traveling a bunch, but your home,
what? Just try it. Try it
for like three or four days.
You could eat a little bit of dog food.
I smell Betsey's every morning at her.
Smells horrendous. But FIV has a
nice wet food. His smells real good.
Would you eat it for a few days? Chicken
gravy. We need it for a couple of days.
I could.
I want to try it as an experiment and
then you should try the, other than that,
no carb thing. It's perfect. The other
thing, I'm sure there's carbs in there.
Not In the wet food that Fifi. It's
this chicken. Well the other thing is,
um, what was the other question?
Oh yeah, so it's a white paper.
I think that part of it is they
squat so deeply when they should. Oh,
like squatty potty. Yeah. If we start,
if we started chatting with one
of those and squatting down more,
like the way you were
meant to actually poop,
I think there'd be less to
clean up. That's really,
really interesting. Answers.
Tell him. Yeah. I think number one, that
means really onto something. Number one,
it's not the food that dictates the dog
shit smell because dogs get into trash
and they, they eat people's food and
they're shit still smells like dog shit.
I think it's the bacteria in
their guts. Number two, uh,
sometimes it gets stuck in there for
like Betsey's had shit stuck to her for.
I think it's cause there's no
hair around the right thing.
We need you to do the dog food thing
to get a real answer because we're just
both,
we're just spinning our wheels where
you give it a shot for us for the show.
Of course.
I'm going to start right after this show.
A lot of people listen to this show.
Do you want me to eat the kibble?
Betsey's kibble. She hasn't. She's on a
special design. You're repulsed by it.
So why don't you start with wet food
just to get into like the flow and maybe
day two you get into some dry food.
If he's got some nice wet,
it does smell good.
His smells like Chinese food kinda.
It smells like a Moo Shu chicken.
It's good. You should try it.
You should try it. I just lick my
fingers after I opened the gate.
Know there's no smell worse on your
dog's back before, right? Yeah. Come
on. Milk bone and the heart treat.
It's not good. It's not good. It's like
a cracker. That's my good is not good.
Have you tried this or this? So
foreign it does. No good. It's no good.
Have you tried it? Oh, um, no.
I've never tried one. Oh, it just
tastes earthy. Shitty. Their,
their, their taste buds are not advanced
like ours where people and where people,
we like people. Yeah, I agree.
I totally think we're
people too. Um, wait,
what did you eat dog food for
a week so we can do this? No,
because you're the one that's got to
do it. Okay. Would you rather? Hello?
Would you rather eat FIFO?
Is Dog food for one day or I take you to
the dog park and that's where you shit
all times.
All Times you have to shit.
You have to shut like a dog in the dog
park with the other dogs. You got a squat
and then I come around with like a
plastic Baggie. Each one to experiments.
No,
I mean one day of dog food versus one
week of shedding the one week because it
has the stakes have to be Sam
to dog food will make you sick.
I don't want to make you
sick for a whole week,
but I would him humiliate you for one.
Why would you want to do that?
Cause painless. Humiliation dies
emotionally painful. All stop.
You'll see your shrink. You'll be fine.
What is wrong with you? He'll be fine.
So what do you choose? Dog? Shit.
What would you choose versus one day of
eating fiefs would you do I need fiefs
food. It smells nice. It's got
that gravy to it. You would vomit.
I will record you vomiting
and play it back to
wait,
but isn't it people you could eat it.
It's like poor quality means you
can't eat anything. Did you know that?
Like you don't have to but you can.
But I'm saying that how far off from,
I mean there's some dirt outside,
you can't eat it. How far off of from
people's food is dog food? Really?
It's off.
Not The nice canned stuff that we give
fif that's off the kibble. Forget it.
But that gravy stuff,
it's nice try by Scott
[inaudible] for the show.
No one bite. No. Why? No,
it's got peas and carrots.
No, no, but you're saying it's not
that Michelle. Yeah, just for the show.
Will you give me,
what do you want me to give you?
Can I think about it? How about let's
make it happen and I just take a taste.
But how big of it to is the Lupus,
but you cannot today though.
But you can't just do, in other words,
there's the, the liquidy kind of part.
You can't just do that. You got to
get it signed out. Like, okay. Like,
like I'm a veggie chunk. Can I not
eat the meat part? Okay, that's fair.
Well, you buy me this, uh, this
ring I was looking at. Okay.
It's not that expensive. All right. It's
like, it's like a hundred bucks. Sure.
All right. Good deal.
I'll try the dog food.
When can we have this experiments episode?
We'll try it on the show. Oh yeah. Okay.
Yeah, absolutely. You just
made a commitment. I know.
Okay. Um, I'm going to,
I have to prepare myself emotionally
for it. All right. I'm really,
really happy that you're just doing this.
Do you think it will make my brown smell?
I think it's too little.
I think if you eat the whole can and
it would make it smell though. Yeah.
What if it's really good and
you just go to town on it?
What's the song that came in? They
sent me, I haven't listened to it.
I couldn't download it on my iPhone.
Try it. You want to call it out?
Let's see if it's any good.
MMM.
Dieudonne [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
what an interesting question.
Did Modus
soundcloud is kid motive music?
I like it.
I want to free my buddy Doug.
I want to free my buddy.
My buddy duct taped
my any
doctor,
you want to know something crazy?
He gonna beat you. Remember that?
I'm patriotic. The live episode we did
in Burbank. It became a Patriot episode.
Yeah. Yeah, we did the podcast live. Um,
remember that guy was the interrupted a
bad, it's just thinking about him. Yeah.
So He's a producer. Producer.
Yeah. His name was tycoon.
He wrote, produced this, uh,
this song. It's kind of a hit right
now. Oh, just blew up. Yeah. 92 bars.
It's this distract from
the game about meek mill.
It's guys
follow.
But he's like Holy Shit.
Like I was at the live show in Burbank
and he talks some shit from the back row.
He was great. I met him after and he
was super nice. So anyways, we were,
we were the yelling about something.
I told him I want to come watch how it
makes a beat. And he said, absolutely.
Oh that's fucking nice. Are you going
to get DJ license from the real deal?
I don't know. I'm going to get DJ lessons,
but I want to see him make a beat.
So he said I could do that.
Nice. I'm excited for you.
Congratulations on the success of 92
bars. Very cool man. Look at that.
See our diverse listenership. You
guys are amazing. Um, very good.
We play the Stan [inaudible],
Stan, Stan Amman.
Why can't believe you guys
this year,
Secretary Clinton became the first
woman nominated for president by a major
party earlier this month.
You said she doesn't have,
this was a big deal. Big Deal.
Then we didn't know this,
but both candidates are
listeners of your mom's. Yeah,
I had no idea.
Have quote a presidential look.
She's standing here, uh, right now.
What did you mean by that?
She doesn't have the look.
She just didn't have the stand ma.
I said she doesn't have the Standard Ama
and I don't believe she does have the
stamina to be president of this country.
You need tremendous stand them up.
You have, wait a minute. She asked me
a question. Did you ask me a question?
You have to be able to
negotiate our trade deals.
You have to be able to negotiate.
Yeah, that's right. With Japan,
with Saudi Arabia,
I mean,
can you imagine we're defending
Saudi Arabia and with all
of the money they have,
we're defending them to,
they're not paying. Well you
have to do is speak to him.
Wait,
you have so many different things you
have to be able to do and I don't believe
that Hillary has the standard
much let her respond.
Wow.
That's from the actual debates.
Trump's a huge fan. David Elliot
sent that in. Thank you, David.
I didn't know that. He was such
a huge fan. There was even a,
wasn't there a video one made to,
a lot of people were on this. Um,
mommies are on the case
mom, um, on the case.
Let me see.
That's a mom on the case.
Who was trimming your beard
back when we took these? Oh,
what did you mean by that?
She doesn't have the look.
She doesn't have the stamina.
I said she doesn't have
the stamina stand him up.
the stamina stand them up.
I don't believe she does have the
stamina to be president of this country.
[inaudible]
that's ty berry. So a couple of people
and we actually have a couple more.
It's not that then. Oh, I love it.
So like Stan Ama is making kind of,
I'm so confused by it now. I do think
it's stand on my now fucked me up man.
Or respond well.
Well as soon as he travels to 112
countries and negotiates a peace deal.
A cease fire. She's got the
stand. A mom who's got it.
All right, Dan. Stan [inaudible], Stan,
Stan Umma it stamina, stamina,
stamina. Sounds wrong.
Why does it sounds so wrong? Because
it does cause Stan. Emma. Yeah.
Now stand on most sounds right.
Does sane it fucked us up.
That and preposition. I've been saying
that wrong now for proposition. Yeah,
it's fucked up when you start
saying their words wrong.
I know we always perfectly say them now,
which is so dumb of us.
He knows names are dummies. What's your
Pronoun Right now? Quick. Your Highness,
Your Majesty, Your Highness.
Was that a university? This
is big and college is now.
So what happens is when a student, when
a student signs on for a, you know,
a new semester classes,
you know everything, a lot
of it is electronic today,
right?
A professor emails his class.
So now when you see those sign offs,
the signature of the
professor has their pronouns.
They allow students to
email in their pronouns.
A University of Michigan did like a
whole campus wide thing where to be
inclusive, name your Pronoun
also as you can name anything.
One of the students there did,
um,
your highness and he said it was to
point out the absurdity of being able to
imagine a teacher having to memorize
everybody's Pronoun and if they fluctuate
every day. Yeah. How has that have
that professor supposed to know?
Yeah, I agree. Um, we've got, uh,
somebody wanted us to rate their
jeans. Oh yeah. I like this game.
If there's deer mountain has,
I have a couple pair of denim jeans that
I've had for about six years wearing
jeans nearly every day.
At this point.
They have worn to the point
they have gotten lighter.
Some have phrase on the bottom.
What is your opinion on denim
that has gotten lighter from age?
It is not very light, but it's
definitely not dark now where I live,
or at least in my childhood home,
the darker jeans were worn by dads.
It was always dark
jeans with nowhere tear,
nearly new looking and the bottom hem,
the fat,
two or three inches above the shoot.
I know exactly what he's talking about.
So for me these Lijing seemed more
appropriate. I have attached pictures.
Yeah, for reference. I
know exactly the type of,
they're like,
just remember this
and I know you think everything
has to do with genes.
Well,
I've been on all,
I know a lot of billionaires
and to the best of my knowledge,
I never saw one wearing
a fucking pair of jeans
just to remind you. Um, okay, so here are,
oh Lord, here are his
jeans. Oh, get your life.
No Bill. Bill. No, no, no. That's
it. That is a no, right Tommy,
those are two knows the one you got
on the one you're holding. Um, no.
I mean the ones you're holding, those
are bad. I know what you're saying.
I just think you need that. You
said two and six years, men,
why don't you just get rid of these?
I know the dad jeans you're talking about,
you know what the other thing you're,
but you left out those dark dad jeans
are real thick and they look terrible.
Like they're cuffed too
high. Right? Like you said,
they get them hemmed like above the
shoe to get them hemmed above the shoe.
How dads do it if they official dads. But
I'm saying he should get a darker wash.
Yeah.
But have it tailored to fit for your
sneakers so that it's like perfect course
to don't don't, I mean there's
a, there's a light Jean,
the kind of works,
but you know these are too
loose or too baggy fitted,
right? Yeah. They're not
fitted and I don't think this
color is good. Just don't,
I think it's too, it's
too light. I tell you,
I got a pair of light denim
recently from lucky works.
A Little Maggie's nineties
style jeans. Yeah. So,
but you know, it's questionable. I
kinda, I like them. No, they work.
I think for dudes,
darker is the way I feel like I want to
take this dude shopping and now where do
you live? I'll go to
the mall with you, Jeff.
I'll go get you. I'll, I'll buy jeans
with you if I'm in new your city. Yeah.
I don't like these.
These are terrible. Jeff.
Get some new fucking jeans, man.
Get Your Life Jeff. Um, all right.
I've got to get going. I got
to take a nap. Oh my God.
I'm so tired. Let's lay down.
Um,
okay.
The closing song is
called top dog loves what?
I can't see what it says. I
teach anima. Dangerous. Um,
all right. Thank you guys for listening.
Don't forget your mom's house.
podcast.com.
Shop through the Amazon banner.
Go to thousand ranch.com for
tickets to see Christina Thompson.
[inaudible] dot Com oh, by the way,
Amazon, we fucking forgot to mention this.
This, there's a new
shirt going on. Sale. Oh,
it's a Dj dad mouth shirt. Oh, my jeans.
I can't believe we went this whole,
she'll put a special announcement at the
top. Okay. And that's a big announcement.
That's a big stinking deal. Okay,
I'll do that. All right. Um,
that's that jeans and
I dunno.
I Dunno. I Mommy's love you. Love you
be the genes. Hello. My name's could
be a Tim team.
The longest cheer boy
ever.
Boy. Boy, boy, boy,
boy, boy, boy,
boy, boy, boy.
I love, we joke. Yeah. Okay.
So I wanted to read some jokes.
Love those.
Okay.
Boy. Boy, boy,
boy, boy, boy,
boy, boy, boy.
Oh my God.
Okay.
You imagine, man, that's funny.
Tom Bride,
can you imagine?
Hey,
your app,
I think their plane ride this stuff here.